remember this it was around this time
last year that the thunderbirds took to
the skies from nellis air force base to
salute our hard-working healthcare
workers
and our community during the early days
of the covet pandemic
that flight plan even dipped down to
lower altitudes to fly over
our local hospitals now boy that video
is incredible fast forward to today
where the thunderbirds once again
flew over the valley take a moment there
it is they kicked off their
2021 show season in cocoa beach florida
before heading to the west coast
they flew over las vegas just before two
o'clock today
flyovers will continue throughout the
season the thunderbirds will use the
same returning routes they used last
year
never not impressive right it never gets
old in fact last week we were saying
they were
actually changing up their uh their
rotation a little bit
uh last week so it's kind of interesting
to see no matter what they do it's
always yes
we're gonna try to spot these slight
variations in rotation